[Musique]
ben
oui un film français qui reçoit une
triple Palme d'Or au Festival de Cannes
ça n'arrive pas tous les 4 matins ça
n'était même jamais arrivé avant
celui-ci euh la vie d'Adel chapitre 1 et
2 est à l'origine l'adaptation de SEP
bande dessinées de Julie Marot à
l'arrivée c'est un film de 3h qui suit
une jeune fille depuis le lycée jusqu'au
début de sa vie professionnelle à
travers une passion amoureuse pour une
autre jeune fille un peu plus âgée
qu'elle d'abord étudiante puis artiste
un film d'initiation une éducation
sentimentale mais aussi social et
artistique écrit par Abdel Latif kchich
et Galia Lacroix interprété par Adel
exarcopoulos Lesa seddou mais aussi
d'autres comédiens qu'il est temps de
citer Salim kchiou Catherine salé
Aurélien coin la charmante Alma
jodorovski le chanteur benam Benjamin
Sisou et la blonde Mona valravens alors
j'ai ici une pile de couverture de
journaux les Cahiers du Cinéma sa film
qui a fait un spécial quéchiche il y a
eu térama toutes les couvertures avec
lesacdou étaient toutes magnifiqu bien
sûr positif le journal où travail
Philippe rouiller encore terama cette
fois c'est Abdel kchich première
euh libération ce weekend adelle du
désir voilà donc c'est vraiment un film
qui a énormément énormément fait couler
dans on le sait les conditions de
tournage du film ont été très discuté on
on propose ici de ne pas y revenir puis
pour se concentrer davantage sur ce qui
se passe à l'écran qui en vaut largement
la peine et vous allez nous le démontrer
tout de suite Émilie oui on vous
proposant de regarder deux scèn ce sont
deux scènes qui se situent dans la
première partie du film qui sont assez
rapprochées peu après la rencontre entre
adelle et Emma la première scène montre
une altercation assez brutale entre
adelle et ses camarade de lycée qui
l'attaque sur sa probable homosexualité
enfin son orientation sexuelle supposée
et la deuxième scène c'est une scène où
Emma fait le portrait d'adelle et en
profite en profite pour lui faire un
petit cours sur Sartre comme ça en pass
oui c'est vrai oui oui voilà donc un la
première par la rupture avec le groupe
avec la doxa la prise de distance et on
voit qu'Adel commence la scène le groupe
au m du groupe et va en sortir et finir
la scène à côté donc une marginalisation
pour dans un deuxième temps deuxème
scène la voir émerger la singularité du
désir qui passe par une drague des yeux
du regard et par la prise en charge
enfin la prise en charge de son destin
dixite Sartre parce qu'évidemment chez
kchis tout de suite il y a l'idée que la
culture l'idée est toujours les
citations ne sont pas au hasard baise d'
ça va c'est bon toi baise
d'oché d c'est bon
m' comme ça tu as quel âge j'aiel c'est
vous avez quel âge je viens de te dire
je suis pas les faut que je te le dise
comment tu es con ou quoiain mais
tu r compte ou pas est-ce que vous
rendez compte ou pas la me la meuf c'est
une elle vient dormir chez moi à
dans mon lit elle me mat le cul quand
elle est chez
moi les C d'accord est-ce que ta meuf
elle aussi la chatte ble
chat ble ta
meuf vasy vasy
vasens tu fa quoi sux pourquoi tu all
dire à M dans bar bord en plus tu l'ASS
tu dis dans pourquo tu faisux que dis on
all dans bar la
fin des ch que j'ai mat son cul pas je
demander
cal j'étais hyper dans M
an faisa du bien surtout dans
l'affirmation de de ma liberté et de mes
propres valeurs tu vois et puis aussi
son exigence dans
l'engagement j'adère complètement ouais
c'est un peu comme Bob Marley quoi
ouais presque je sais pas je suis pas
sûr moi je suis presque sûr bah les
idées elles se rejoignent un peu tu vois
le son get up stand up bah ouais je vois
bah je trouve qu'il est engagé
ouais c'est vrai c'est pareil que ça
c'est un peu un philosophhe c'est un
prophète c'est la même chose en tout cas
j'espère que tu voudras bien m'aider
pour mes dis de philo parce que tu as
l'air mais écoute quand tu
veux Philippe étiez-vous hyper Sartre
dans vos années lycées bien sûr bien sûr
tout comme adelle moi tout tout tout cô
côe pareil parce que voilà quand le film
a commencé on a vu cette jeune fille
cette cette poste adolescente qui
sortait de chez elle pour louper son bus
et tout de suite je suis venu avec elle
et et c'est un film qui qui me lâche pas
pendant 3h et ce que je trouve
formidable dans la mise en scène de
keschich c'est la question de à quelle
distance on se met pour que nous
spectateur on est une place comment on
va être avec le personnage en fait c'est
marrant ça s'appelle la vie d'adè ça
s'appelle pas le bleu est une couleur
chaude ça s'appelle pas adè et Emma et
toutes les scènes où il y avait pas adè
il les a coupé hein au montage parce que
elle rentrait pas dans le film parce que
en fait le film nous invite à être avec
elle et alors vous avez vu cette échelle
de plan ça veut dire qu'on sort organise
vraiment pour tourner Mo vraiment il
faut citer son chef opérateur sopian
alfani qui qui est quelqu'un qui avant
était cadreur sur ses trois précédents
films il l'a fait monter chefop et tout
en étant chefopérateur il tient une
caméra et il y a un autre cadreur et
donc tout le film est tourné à deux
caméras sauf les scènes de foule où il y
en a où où il y en a trois si bien que
les les champs contre-champs comme on a
vu tout à l'heure sont des vrais champs
contre-champs c'est-à-dire
qu'habituellement on fait le champ et
puis après on fait le contrechamp là on
on tourne en perman manence le champ le
contrechant et j'allais dire les champs
les contrechamps parce que c'est un
cinéma sans Clape c'est pas le seul à
faire ça il beaucoup beaucoup de
gens oui mais toute façon il y a une
école maywen je suis sûr j'en ai pas
parlé avec elle mais je suis sûr qu'elle
adore le SAT kchich et il y a cette idée
de désacraliser le club de tourner
tourner et il faut que les les
opérateurs soient toujours là pour
capter le le le bon endroit ça veut dire
que mine de rien faut qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui fasse le point je parle de
choses techniques parce que c'est
technique pour réuss
avoir ce naturel là ce réalisme là et au
bout du compte qu'est-ce qu'on voit on
voit une jeune fille qui devient une
femme et une et le devenir d'une actrice
c'est pour ça qu'on a pu parler aussi à
nos amours Sandrine Bonner quand je suis
sorti en 82 de à nos amours je oh une
actrice est né et cetera les gens me dis
bon calme-toi tu la trouves très bien et
cetera elle peut jouer que ça c'est une
gamine et tout et non c'était et et là
je suis sûr que si les gros poissons la
mangent pas adelarchopoulos ce sera une
très très grande actrice parce que là
elle se déploie d'une scène à l'autre
elle est différente et ce qui est
formidable c'est que la caméra de kchich
filme les sensations filme les humeurs
alors on a beaucoup dit que c'est ça
qu'il avait incité à la choisir hein
cette manière d'avoir la bouche ouverte
et moi je trouve ça d'une sensualité
sont les liquides ce sont les larmes la
morou et la cine après dans les scènes
de sexe mais je veux dire il y il y a
une continuité on est constamment et et
le bruit c'est-à-dire que bah vous bavez
ça s'entend euh votre sexe su if ça
s'entend aussi et je veux dire on n pas
vu souvent des scènes de sexe où on
entend o on entend l'humidification on
entend le frolement des caresses c'est
lirisme fou c'est d' lirisme fou c'est
extraordinaire on peut passer du lirisme
du nature du naturalisme au lyisme en
permanence dans le film et comme c'est
en deux parties on sait qu'évidemment
dans une histoire d'amour ça ça finit
mal en général et
bien l'horreur est déjà inclu dans le
bonheur et ça c'est extraordinaire quand
on a entendu cette chanson qu'on a mis
en début de ce débat là c'est pour
l'anniversaire de c'est pour
l'anniversaire d'adelle elle est tout
seule à cet anniversaire là elle vient
d'avoir son amoureuse et on sent déjà la
déchirante solitude et on se dit
qu'est-ce qu'on va déguster dans l'heure
et demi qui nous attend derrière
qu'est-ce qu'on va souffrir avec adelle
Marie vous avez souffert vous aussi vous
l'avez vu vous l'avez vu à Cannes ou l'z
revu après à Paris je l'ai vu à Paris et
alors c'est c'est compliqué parce que
moi je suis pas du tout kchichienne
voilà jamais et j'aime beaucoup ce film
disons que ce film me passionne sans
forcément m'émouvoir beaucoup ce qui
peut être un problème et ce qui tient
peut-être aussi à cette méthode qui est
une méthode qu'on appelle d'épuisement
ou d'exaspération voilà épuisement du
jeu des actrices et pour atteindre ce
que kchich appelle cette vérité qui
cherche comme un comme un dingue et
aussi des scè épuisement du spectateur
parfois mais moi j'ai comment dire c'est
pas négatif quand je dis ça c'est-à-dire
que je me bagarre énormément avec les
films de kchich et je crois que je vais
finir par aimer ça il vous aura eu la
Lure qui
ouuli qui fait effectivement 3 He qui
sont pas du tout 3 He de souffrance je
pense que le film est qu'il est parce
qu'il fait 3h voilà et qui pouvait pas
certainement faire moins euh je dis pas
que j'en aurais pris trois de plus comme
j'ai lu parfois à can parce que parfois
à can les gens écrivent aussi n'importe
quoi non mais ils écrivent aussi moi
jeai je l'ai beaucoup lu par exemple ah
c'est pas du tout une histoire d'amour
homosexuel c'est pas un film ah ben
alors si si c'est et on le voit bien
c'estàd que la construction
elle fait ai dans le rejet des autr dans
la sore groupe et que si c'était juste
l'histoire d'une fille qui rencontre un
garçon c'est le début du film c'est rien
c'est
aussiionstacles oui mais ce qui est
assez fascinant dans le film c'est le
fait que cette histoire qui est une
histoire d'amour homosexuel avec ce que
ça implique de révélation d'acceptation
de lutte de trouille devient à la fin
une histoire d'amour absolument comme
n'importe quel autre c'est que la force
du film c'est de montrer aussi ça c'est
pas un film à sujet c'est pas un film à
thèse on est n'est pas là pour ça mais
sauf que sauf qu'on se balade et et
qu'elle
arrivé oui je sais Mar je peux pas te
laisser dire ça tu dis que le film est
bien alors que moi je trouve qu'il est
bien non mais il est passionnant attends
mais il y a des gens qui vont
souffrir il y a des gens qui vont
souffrir très grave que manger des
spaghetti en gros plan pendant des
plombes je sais que François
adoreaget lon notre bien tout le monde
trouve ça très bien chez lon ou al non
mais sauf que il y a quand même il y a
quand même une répétition de film en
film par exemple je trouve un peu
ballourd voilà le marquage social des
familles le marage social des person les
pauvres mangent des spaghettis et les
riches mangent des
Hz vous savez que les
h pour remettre justement un petit peu
de de tension non pas dans ce débat mais
disons dans la réception de ce fil parce
que le danger de quchich c'est qui
s'académise pas lui mais la réception
s'académise moi je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec toi Marie je pense
qu'effectivement c'est vrai que c'est
des c'est des homosexuels et et c'est
une part du film conséquente je suis
d'accord avec toi mais le vrai point de
clivage le le glissement coper kchich
très malin redoutable moi je trouve le
film redoutable en fait et je trouve que
tout ce que j'entends sur lui je trouve
que c'est trop pacifié redoutable parce
qu'il est redoutablement marxiste et il
va il pousse très très loin la lutte des
classes parce que justement il il dit
finalement la question homosexuelle
n'est pas une question c'est quand même
ce que dit le film c'estàd que du côté
évidemment de la bourgeoisie c'est tout
à fait accepté et du côté des un peu
plus prolo on sent bien qu'elle se cache
qu'elle s'autocensure mais finalement
c'est pas traité scénaristiquement donc
ce n'est pas le sujet du traité là
cétait traité dans la bande
des trité violemment dans la bande des
il faut savoir que la scène qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure où où les deux filles à
l'école lui disent ouais ça le laisse
bien tu as dormi à poil dans mon lit
n'aura aucune suite scénaristique donc
qu'est-ce qui se joue dans le film c'est
beaucoup plus et je crois que là-dessus
c'est vraiment malin de sa part vous
croyez que je vais vous parler de les
homosexuels contre le champ social et
sur le mode de interdiction
transgression mais pas du tout je vais
au contraire resituer la ligne de front
sur la lutte des classes parce que ce
qui se passe entre les sdou et et Adel
et si je dis lesassdou d'ailleurs le nom
de l'actrice c'est que je crois kchich
dans son sa grande malice n'a pas pris
lesassdou pour rien et c'est que c'est
voilà évidemment que ce n'est pas d'
doodin qu' est choisi le le le passif
bourgeois de l'actrice lesassdou pour
qu'elle joue em ma ce qui se passe entre
elle et ce qui j'ai jamais enfin vu la
lutte des classes poussé à un tel point
je dirais de de de d'insupportabilité
pour certains c'est que le film à mon
avis dit et montre en permanence que les
bourgeois sont incapables d'amour je
vais vous le dire je vous la fait un peu
brutal comme ça que je crois que le film
est quand même travaillé par cette
affaire là je dis pas que ce soit une
thèse à laquelle on doit adhérer mais
prenons le film j'entends bien mais je
pense que le film est travaillé par ça
parce que K est un dingue Ding
l'impression que le film est travaillé
par un désamour à tous les dans tous les
lieux où l'individu l'individu grandit
évolue la famille en fait le truc de K
c'est qu'il verrouille tous les milieux
tous les lieux où on évolue la famille
c'est mort qu'elle soit bourge ou
populaire c'est mort l'histoire d'amour
c'est est mort le couple il est condamné
et l'école est le seul lieu j'entends
dans l'enceinte de la classe chez des
adolescents comme chez des enfants où le
un épanouissement humain du de
l'individu est possible et en fait la
vraie histoire d'amour de ce film c'est
c'est la déclaration de kchich au
miracle républicain c'est juste ça il y
a pas l'histoire d'amour elle est pas
ailleurs l'histoire entre adelle et Emma
elle est comme vous aimez tous Michel va
parler bien sûr mais je sens qu'il y a
unanimité je vais quand même lire la
chronique d'éic neof Eric neof du Figaro
qui dit au bout d'un moment ça ressemble
à un combat de catch de Borat là il
parle des scènes de sexe euh il dit
quchich filme avec un piala sur la
langue ce naturalisme Patau ces images
saturées de quotidien ce ce réalisme
exponentiel n'exigeait peut-être pas une
triple palme d'or à Canne remplacer les
amantes par un homme et une femme il ne
reste rien kchich à qui on a trop dit
qu'il était un génie garde tout il ne
serait pas inutile de lui offrir une
paire de ciseaux Michell vous voulez
réagir c'est c'est quand même c'est
c'est quand même dommage qu'on puisse
presque plus débattre mais bien s
votre unanimité mais non mais on va pas
travestir tu détestes le film tu
détestes le film déteste pas le film je
pense qu'un point de vue différent est
possible et NOTAM la PR c'est pe débatt
de ce que dit bah éc le fait le le seul
problème du film effectivement c'est son
côté écrasant pour les autres films
effectivement le film a une triple Palme
d'Or donc on a l'impression qu'il y a
que ça qui qui sort cette semaine et on
ne parle que de ça c'est mais là kich en
est pas able qu il s'est contenté de
faire un excellent film donc il y a il y
a effectivement cette cette question et
c'est peut-être ça qui AG voilà trouvez
pas un peu TR long aurit mon non non non
c'est pas trop long mais il a il y a
cette question de la conscience de
classe qui est omniprésente dans le film
c'est une question qui marque les
personnages qui marque la famille d'Adel
Adel qui est qui pourrait rêver d'une
vie d'écrivain si par exemple elle était
née avec une cuère d'argent mais
justement mais mais justement mais c'est
ce que je suis en train de
dire on est d'accord c'est ce qu'il est
en train de dire il est en train de dire
que Ding qu' on qu'elle vient d'une
famille qu'elle vient d'une famille de
de de prolo qui qui aurait qui aurait
été qu' aurait accédé à la classe
moyenne mais qui est toujours qui a
toujours aussi cette idée de de classe
qu'on ne peut pas aller trop loin qu'on
ne peut pas et et finalement c'est
qualifé de Bourdin Bourdin je sais pas
si j'ur c'estàd que les gens sont
déterminés par
moi je pense par exemple je pense tout
le cont juste sur la longueur pardon sur
l'absence des ciseaux absolus là où il
faut absolument pas de ciseaux c'est que
une scène d'amour avec des coupé ça ça
ça empêcherait que à ce que la scène
évolue en scène de combat et c'est ça
qui est dingue c'est que chaque début de
scè d'abour chez kchich se finit en
radeau de la Méduse et pour ça il faut
du temps c'est-à-dire c'est on n'est pas
juste dans l'érotises la sensalité
qu'est-ce que c'est oui cétait déjà le
cas dans la graine et le mulet avec la D
suiv la viol la viol mais mais obligé
d'adorer ça tu peux tu peux te bagarrer
avec le film parce que de temps en temps
tu étouffes et que moi de temps en temps
j'aurais bien voulu l'avoir à côté de
moi et lui dire mais film-moi un
plan large j'en peux plus d'être dans le
nez dans la bouche dans l'oreille de la
fille et cetera sauf que c'est ce qui
fait que le film est inoubliable et sauf
que j'ai rarement vu les prémises d'un
baiser dire autant le désir au cinéma
voilà c'estd que les actrices parlent de
quelque chose et nous on sait on sait
grâce à l'image que c'est pas du tout ça
qui se joue et ce qu'on attend c'est le
baiser et la montée très lente et très
désirable de se baiser est absolument
génial laisine le rapport entre la
cuisine et le y a très peu de Gou alors
en même temps ve le rapport entre l're
et le sexe de la femme moi je le trouve
très
agré Mang des spagettis m
spagettis
m ils aiment tous ils aiment tous le
même film ils arrivent à se disput alors
vous souvenez on mangeait le couscous on
mangeait le couscous PhIP Alice mit ça
vous dit quelque chose avant
d'interroger les étoiles je vous propose
d'accueillir notre invité une jeune
scénariste et réalisatrice qui a quatre
t métrage à son active Alice mitteran
bonsoir vous préparez votre premier long
oui c'est vrai c'est un film qui
s'appelle mon piramie une comédie noire
c'est pas trop difficile en ce moment
c'est c'est très compliqué hein c'est
pas facile c'est pas facile alors je
voulais entendre votre avis Alice sur la
vie d'adè vous avez découvert le film
hier dans une vraie salle de cinéma avec
du vrai public est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ce ce ce quintê alors
j'étais très contente d'aller voir ce
film parce que j'aime beaucoup le cinéma
de keschich donc j'étais j'étais ravie
et puis au fur et à mesure du film je
suis prise d'un d'une impression d'un
sentiment que j'essaie de mettre de côté
mais je commence à m'ennuyer et pourtant
je trouve adelle passionnante évidemment
je tombe amoureuse d'elle je pense comme
nous tous lesdou est extraordinaire
aussi la mise en scène enfin je peux pas
contester tout ça évidemment je suis
d'accord avec tout ce que vous dites
mais je suis quand même je suis quand
même un peu réfractaire à tout ça je
m'ennuie je suis très gênée par les
scènes chez les parents bourgeois je
trouve qu'il parle comme dans une site
comom tout ça est très angélique ses
parents bourgeois pseudo libérés qui
parle comme personne dans la vie qui
explique l'huîre c'est merveilleux les
raffinements de il faut mettre du citron
et si ça bouge ça veut dire que c'est
frais inatire c'est in satire ou pas
enfin il se moque quand il les film oui
mais ça me dérange parce que tout le
reste quand même très réaliste et très
naturaliste et très juste et tout à coup
cette scène n'est pas juste qu'est-ce
qui aura pas juste dans la scène par
exemple précisément par exemple le vin
blanc est-ce que c'est pas juste est-ce
que par exemple de soigner la bouteille
qu'on a commandé et cetera et de dire
regardez et de la goûter est-ce que
c'est pas est-ce que les bourgeois ne
font pas ça alors si les bourgeois font
ça mais je ne crois pas qu'ils en
parlent comme
ça non c'est vrai qu'on peut on peut
trou on peut parfois trouver que les
dialogues pourrait être plus travaillé
plus brillant plus plus écrit mais mais
c'est très frappant quand elle parle
d'art par exemple he c'est c'est quand
même des des filles qui ont fait les
beauards les deux trois trucs qu'elles
échangent sur la peinture à
r Je t'ai voir quelques étudiants en art
VO vous êtes pas allé ass
au la façon dont tu parles de Sartre je
veux dire moi je défie quel 22 ans que
ça mais mais pourquoi c'est très juste
par exemple le rire le rire de sdou au
moment où elle fait où adelle fait une
comparaison avec Bob Marley le rire de
sdou est un rire hyper juste et hyper
dégueulasse hyper hyper condescendant
socialement et tout est là oui mais là
attention vous êtes condescendant avec
notre invité et les scènes de sexe alors
j'ai un vrai problème c'est-à-dire que
je suis embarrassée je suis gêné
d'assister à tout ça il y a un moment
donné où j'ai j'ai vraiment le sentiment
enfin je me dis mais qu'est-ce que je
fais là quoi ça ne me regarde pas tout
ça j'ai l'impression qu'on me dit
regardez ce documentaire sur la vie
sexuelle des lesbiennes regardez ce qui
se passe techniquement vous les hétéros
vous allez voir enfin ce qui se passe
dans les chambres des lesbiennes et et
je suis un peu gêné tout ça on pe le
voir sur certains sites hein sur c'est
facile à trouver hein enfin oui oui une
fois pour une fois que pardon hein mais
pour je dire on peut penser c'est pareil
à l'OND de quoi est-ce qu'on juge cette
scène moi j'entends des gens me dire
ouais mais c'est pas ça le sex lesbien
ça peut m'intéresser je mais qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire de juger faut jamais
juger le réalisme en fonction de sa
représentativité ce qu'il faut juger
c'est l'énergie interne de cette scène
et et la jugé je dirais presque en terme
de cinéma c'estàdire est-ce que vous
avez déjà vu une scène de sexe comme ça
au cinéma est-ce que vous en aviez pas
marre un petit peu que la scène de sexe
dans un film soit toujours tronqué en
réglé en 10 secondes avec une espèce de
voilà de de
position
viment les de sexe moi ce que je pense
c'est que kich ne filme pas la réalité
d'une scène de sexe entre lesbien il
filme son fantasme du sexe lesbien et il
le dit très bien au milieu du film il y
a un type qui dit l'orgasme féminin ça
doit être fou c'est génial il le dit
clairement à ce momentlà il monte son
jeu de carartte et il dit voilà moi
c'est ça que je filme c'est mon fantasme
de ce sexe
là ça vous arrange et puis sinon c'est
du fantasme quand ça vous arrange moi je
dis juste qu'il y a tout le temps de la
sublimation je dis pas qu' moi j'ai
jamais employé ce motl ce mot-là dans le
film de cinéma de kchich me semble
impropre sur les scènes de sexe
évidemment que parfois on fait ça
évidemment parce que parfois on fait ça
aussi parce que c'est compliqué ces
scènesl parce qu'elles sont très
inconfortables Mo je suis d'accord avec
ça dans la dans le dans la salle où vous
étiez vous avez écouté un peu à la
sortie est-ce que les gens trouvent
qu'on en a trophé sur sur ce film trois
palmes d'or j'ai j'ai malheureusement
pas pu vraiment prend la température
faire une interview à la sortie de la
salle il y avait en tout a vraiment
beaucoup de monde mais voilà moi je je
je suis un peu bloquée par aussi la
banalité de cette histoire qui me qui ne
me prend pas malgré tout ce qui est mis
en place bon alors maintenant et
laissons la conclusion aux
[Musique]
étoiles